la ville d'Amboise dans un piège
inextricable une paralysie politique
devenue concrète hier soir en conseil
municipal c'est bien simple tous les
projets du mairelr Thierry Boutard ont
été retoqués par l'opposition une
opposition devenue majoritaire depuis de
récentes d'émission un bras de fer que
nous racontera des villes
19 délibérations au programme du Conseil
Municipal d'Amboise autant de
délibérations rejetées l'opposition
devenue majoritaire depuis la défection
cette semaine de trois colistiers de
Thierry Boutard étant très dans un
rapport de force frontale avec le maire
le comportement de maire du premier
magistrat de la ville c'est pas un
comportement j'allais dire de partage et
d'union alors que moi j'ai plutôt une
tendance à être un peu plus en consensus
et de rassemblement alors que lui il est
dans la division 19 fois ce fut le même
scénario un vote à bulletin secret et un
maximum de 16 voix pour 33 ça ne suffit
pas l'opposition canal historique
conteste les méthodes du maire qu'elle
considère comme autocratique et démontre
par le jeu politique qu'elle détient de
fait le pouvoir il n'a pas compris que
actuellement il est en minorité à
Amboise donc à lui de prendre toutes les
responsabilités et ses responsabilités
là elles sont elle se faire de repasser
devant les électeurs voilà acculé et
impuissant face au blocage de
l'opposition tire-boutard est apparu
fataliste comme spectateur d'un conseil
municipal qu'il ne contrôle plus le
maire d'Amboise et surtout amer du vote
de ses anciens alliés je tiens à
rappeler que ces oppositions dont deux
groupes ont été élus sur un projet
municipal à mes côtés et que il en vient
de leur responsabilité face aux
amboisiens de faire assumer ce projet
municipal pour les amboisiens que les
amboisiens ont choisi après les pics de
début de séance les banderies lors des
votes l'opposition impose au maire de
convoquer un conseil municipal
extraordinaire dans les 30 jours à
l'ordre du jour la délégation de pouvoir
Homer ce jour-là l'opposition lui
enlèvera Thierry Boutard n'aura de mer
que le titre